now I don't know about you but i think
this manual bug hunting is a little bit
tedious so why don't we introduce you to
some tools that will make our lives a
little bit easier all the major browsers
have developer tools built into them
that can help you with just the kind of
problems that we were looking at and
then some now if you're watching this in
google chrome you can open the developer
tools i'm moving over here new tools and
clicking on developer tools now you can
see that there's a handy little shortcut
here depending on what platform you're
on that shortcut might be different on
Mac its command option I and you can see
that it opens up this console here and
if we were to load our file with bugs
into it then you can see that it starts
catching syntax errors now only goes so
far and then it just crashes but you can
see that it points us to the first
syntax error here and then we can fix
them as necessary if we kept going with
this by fixing this let's say and then
reloaded the page we would see that it
would get to the next error which is
right in this for loop now you notice
that it skipped right over this error
here didn't even catch it because the
way JavaScript handles semicolons